寝起きです
やばい
眠すぎっ
てか顔がぼったぼたな感じがしますね
はい
今日はとある実験をしてみようと思います
みなさんドアには２種類あるのは
知ってますか？
私の住んでいる東京の家にも
押すドアと引くドアが
たくさん部屋の中にあるんですけれども
ドアを見た瞬間
ましてやもういつもこうつんでるわけじゃないし
めちゃくちゃ使い慣れてるわけでもなこの部屋のドア
ボクですら
ドアをパッと見た瞬間に
そのドアが引くドアか押すドアかっていうのは
わからないんですよね
ボク以外の人はこの部屋のドアが果たしてこのドアが
押すドアか引くドアかっていうのは
パッと見た瞬間
わからないと思うんですよ
感覚的な問題でしかない
まじで眠そうだな、、顔が
(パンっ)
あ''ぁ！
この部屋の中には
この２枚を貼っていこうと思います
これだけで多分ね
脳の情報を操作できると思うんですよ
これを貼ればどんなドアも
押すドアだと勘違いする
これを貼るばどんなドアでも
引くドアだと勘違いしてしまう
果たしてターゲットはどういう反応を
示すのでしょうか
CHECK
ひぃぃぃいいい
引くを貼ります
引く
押すと開くから
(フフフ、、、)
引く側だから押すだな
(ハハハッ)
引くと開くから押すですね
バッチリっす
いや、、押したくなるなこれは
あぁ、おはようございます
(ﾆﾔﾆﾔ)
なんかそれおかしくないっスか？
んっ？
(ﾆﾔﾆﾔ)
押すなのに押したら、、
前からそんなんでしたっけ？
うめぇ～
いや、オレこれやられたなぁ
え？
いや、コレやりましたねぇ？
あれ？
(ﾆﾔﾆﾔ)
あっ、でも違うか、、
え？これ、、
絶対、、これ、、、
こんなんだったっけ、、？ほんとに、、
なに？なに？なに？？
(笑)
怪しすぎるんだよなぁ～
ハッハッハッハッハッ